the Powerball has reached 700 million
dollars it is the is the largest
Powerball jackpot ever so
live in the Arizona State Line as people
line up for a chance to win Sasha
Denise and Brian we've been here at
Arizona last stop all afternoon it's
about 30 miles past the Hoover Dam on
the way to Kingman definitely a lot of
people trickling in and out all day you
can see quite a few here using that
machine to pick Powerball numbers to get
a chance at that 700 million dollar
jackpot can you imagine that's about a
335 dollar or million dollar rather cash
value there's also an option where you
can fill it out old-fashioned and put
your numbers in like that now again
about 45 minutes they're selling them
until about seven o'clock so you have 45
minutes to get down here or to Prim
which is over of course on the
California Nevada state line and the
tickets are about two dollars each so
definitely a lot of people coming down
here to try their luck reporting live
Sasha Loftus 8 News Now